Hey there, everyone.
I've got something to show you
that's been almost a year in
the making.
I've just received it today.
I'm a little bit excited.
Let me grab it.
Here it is.
This is a printed tartan based
on the Fibonacci sequence.
And if that doesn't excite you,
well, you're probably
watching the wrong
YouTube channel.
There it is.
And if that's not good enough,
I also have a ribbon of the
same design, Fibonacci
tartan ribbon.
So I'm not going to bore you
with wefts and warps and all
the terminology of tartan, or
plaid, as I think people in
the US might call it.
But basically, it's a very
number-based thing to make.
And the rows and the threads
that have been used to create
this design are based on
the Fibonacci sequence.
So we've got 1, 1, 2, 3, 5,
8, 13, 21, 34, 55, 89.
And I must say it's
pretty impressive.
I'm really pleased with it.
So I'm going to give
you a closer look.
But while I do, I'm going to
play a piece of music from our
favorite musician here at
Numberphile, Alan Stewart,
who's been making all sorts of
bits of music for us lately.
And he's actually composed a
piece of bagpipes music based
on the Fibonacci sequence.
And this is properly based on
the Fibonacci sequence in lots
of different ways.
So when you're listening to it,
see how many of them you
can identify.
If you don't like bagpipes,
I would suggest skipping--
in fact, I'll tell you exactly
how much to skip.
Basically, skip one minute and
30 seconds, because that's how
long this is going
to play for.
But it is very cool.
[BAGPIPE MUSIC PLAYING]
It was a bit of an effort
to have this made.
At times, it felt like a
battle of Braveheart
proportions.
But I do want to thank the House
of Tartan, who are the
people who finally got
this done for me.
And if you want to design your
own pattern or buy a tartan or
find out more about
it, I strongly
suggest their website.
Of course, also thanks to Alan
for his piece of music.
We'll have more about
that soon.
So see how much Fibonacci you
saw in there, and we'll come
back to it.
You're probably wondering what
I'm going to do with this.
And I'm wondering the
same, to be honest.
I've got a few ideas, a few ways
I might be able to share
it with you guys, the viewers.
But if you've got any
suggestions, it's not too late
to put something underneath
the video.
And I'll be back soon with
more information.
One last thank you, and that's
to the people at audible.com
for supporting this
Numberphile video.
And actually, they've got an
offer at the moment, if you're
in the US or Canada,
where if you go to
audible.com/numberphile, you
can download one of their
100,000 audiobooks for free.
I was having a look through
thinking what
one should I recommend.
Should it be some Scottish
poetry or something like that?
But then I saw that they have
"Alex's Adventures in
Numberland." Alex Bellos you may
have seen in some of our
early Numberphile videos.
And he's got a brilliant
book about numbers.
So go along,
audible.com/numberphile.
Go for your free book.
So thanks again to everyone at
audible.com, because they let
people like me do crazy things
like make Fibonacci tartans.
I do like it.